and my second movie was um American
Gangster that movie was bad Washington
yeah yeah and rley Scott directing for
sure um I mean what's it like acting
next to somebody like Denzel Washington
who's at the top of the top you know
what I mean like the [__] feels I
mean I I can't even I can't even put it
in the words what I will say is for this
scene right here where he and I were you
know uh
together uh and it was just he and I in
the scene um before we shot this scene I
was walking pacing back and forth having
you know a moment you know what I'm
saying just you know just going over my
lines and and he looked at me he said
man you
nervous and I said well kind of man just
you know making sure I don't [__] this
up he said man come here he say look
they could have had anybody else right
here here doing this what you doing
right I said yeah he said but they
called you right I said yeah he said do
you know why they called you do you know
what you did to make him call you I said
yeah he said all right [__] do that
then we ain't got no reason to
be yeah you know and uh and that that
that was the the what he said before we
shot this scene D that's awesome man I
loved that movie yeah and so so coming
off of those two movies going into the
takers you know I just took everything
that I had learned from my first two
experiences and applied it you know and
I had so many strong strong actors and
and and characters around me from uh the
late great Paul Walker to Idris Alba to
Chris Brown Hayden Christen Michael
elely you know Zoe Sal Don it was a lot
of us um and all I had to do is show up
and contribute that was a fun movie yeah
it was it was
was um see you got the you're producing
movies acting in movies with the with
all the music and then like still the
construction business yeah we just uh we
just actually my my my first my first
commercial development is a a mixed use
affordable housing Apartment Company
yeah in Atlanta yeah we just cut the
ribbon on on on that congratulations my
girl was in bed last last night and and
and uh you know we're both just on our
phones and I I I looked at my girl and I
said man we are both so helplessly
addicted to our phones it's pathetic and
she goes yeah but look at this and she's
looking at at your affordable housing
project I was like oh man that's so
killer yeah I appreciate it but you know
what I'm saying it's uh I I kind of
weaned myself off of the self like the
the Social Media stuff man this it's
definitely uh distracting yeah yeah yeah
it's terrible man can can you talk about
the the uh the affordable housing
complex sure what uh it's 140 units 143
yeah and it's all in Atlanta yeah and
you built this with your own
construction company or you bought it
and you took it over and you give it
back no no no no so I acquired the I
acquired the land and I um I dedicated
it to this project that uh I conceived
or or we me and my team collectively
conceived and and found partners and
that partnership kind of grew the
capital stack grew um it's it's private
funds as well as public
funds um and and you know so many people
uh had to have a hand in in in bringing
that Vision to a reality including
the mayor and Andre Dickens uh the
former mayor mayor Kesha Lance bottoms
uh the vincino group uh myself and the
the the team of supporters I have around
me it's
great yeah that's right it seems like
you have the mightest touch I don't know
about that I I do some [__] up too
yeah you we're only talking about the
Highlight Reel here I've done my sh
[__] up too I mean you have your hand
in so many different pots at what age
did this Hustler mentality come about
you know what I mean fourth grade fourth
grade and you started rapping pretty
young too like was it third grade 8
years old and what is an eight-year-old
rapping about man to be honest with you
growing up without a daddy having to
focus on school when you don't want to
and you know trying to find ways to to
be the man of the house when it's just
you and your mama it's a lot of pressure
yeah well you know pressure buz pipes
and make diamonds
there you go see what I'm saying might
touch it's crazy what you say pressure
busts pipes and makes diamonds either oh
yeah dude do you like shopping on Amazon
I do and good news is sto's butt wipes
for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and steo butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude